إذاً أين نحن في ميدان مارشر
، هذا قلب وسط بيروت ، إذا
كنت قد أتيت إلى هنا قبل الحرب الأهلية ،
كانت هذه حقًا محطة الحافلات الرئيسية
في البلد الذي وصل إليه الجميع إلى بيروت
هنا كانت مزدحمة وانظر إليها عندما
أقول فارغة  جوهرة
لا يوجد شيء يحدث هنا ،
لا يوجد أشخاص ، لا يوجد مواصلات عامة
، لا يوجد عمل حيث كانت
ساحة انتظار سيارات فارغة تنتظر شخصًا ما
لشرائها حتى يتمكنوا من بناء
مبنى آخر فارغ ، هذا تمثال
تم بناؤه بواسطة المتظاهرين
وتم بناؤه  من مواد
الخيام التي تم تدميرها في مرحلة
ما ، ما هو طائر الفينيق الذي
يخرج من كشف الرماد ، حسنًا ،
ما الذي يريدونه ، ما الذي تريدونه جميعًا
، أعني أننا نريد بلدًا
يعمل مكانًا حيث  يمكن أن تعيش
ما تريده للتخلص من
الأخرى الموجودة واستبدالها
بما يحل محله أشخاص
أكفاء يتمتعون ببعض الاستقلالية
عن النخبة السياسية الحالية التي
لديها  يديرون البلاد على مدار الثلاثين
عامًا الماضية ولم يتمكنوا حقًا من
طرح أي نوع من سياسة التنمية الوطنية ،
انظر إلى ما حدث في الدولة التي
أفلست ، لا تسمح البنوك
للناس بالحصول على أموالهم ، فالدين يعتبر
دراماتيكيًا ولكنك ستفعل  توافق على أنه على
المدى القصير ، سيتعين عليك الاستمرار
في نفس المجموعة إلى حد كبير
لأنهم هم الذين يعرفون كيفية إدارة
الأشياء ، يبدو أنه لا يوجد تعويذة
حيث يمكنك فقط تغيير كل شيء ويتم تغييره
ولكن ما نطمح إليه
يضع عملية تغيير
، وأعتقد حقًا أن هذه العملية
قد حدثت ، وهذا هو نوع الشيء
الذي كان نعم ، هذه هي
الانقسامات التي حدثت هنا
حيث حاول الجيش ، ولا سيما
قوة الشرطة في البرلمان ،
منع المتظاهرين من الدخول إلى
البرلمان ، وبالتالي كان هناك العديد
من التفاعلات العنيفة بين
المتظاهرين وأمن الحزب.
وعندما
يقول رئيس الوزراء إنه لن يقف ،
فإنه سوف يسلمها ، لقد انتهى ، لقد
فعل ذلك نعم سيدي ، لقد انتهى الأمر إلى اللقاء ،
نعم ، هذا رائع ، كل واحد
منهم يغادر أمر رائع لأن رئيس
الوزراء يمثل نموذجًا للتنمية الاقتصادية
لقد فشل ذلك ،
هل هناك شخص ما ينتظر في الأجنحة
هناك الكثير من الأشخاص العظماء
القادرين على تولي السلطة إذا كان هناك
دعم سياسي كافٍ من
القواعد الشعبية للاحتفاظ بهم فعليًا
والحفاظ عليهم في السلطة ، يبدو أنهم
اقتربوا من أشخاص أكفاء للغاية
وطلبوا منهم ذلك  أن تكون في الحكومة
والظروف هي عادة أنه يتعين عليك
الذهاب والتحدث إلى الطبقة السياسية الحالية
والتنسيق معها
وهذه هي المشكلة إذا كنت تريد حقًا
تغييرًا تغييرًا جذريًا ، فأنت بحاجة إلى
شخص من خارج
الطبقة السياسية تمامًا إذا كان هذا هو الحال.  ليس ممكنًا ،
فأنت بحاجة على الأقل للتأكد من أن
الأشخاص الذين يأتون إلى هنا يمكنهم
توجيهك خلال هذه الفترة الانتقالية
التي حصلت عليها  صندوق النقد الدولي على بابك
، ربما تكون هناك حرب إقليمية تحدث ، ربما
تحتاج إلى حماية هذا البلد ،
ليس من المجدي التفكير في أنه يمكننا الحفاظ على
العمل كالمعتاد حيث لا نعمل.
لبنان مريض مصاب
بالسرطان وأنت مستعجل بشكل أساسي  هذا
المريض إلى المستشفى وبينما تقوم
بنقل المريض إلى المستشفى
يعاني من نوبة قلبية وهي في الأساس
الأزمة المالية التي نعيشها
وتعتقد أنها مروعة ولا
تعرف ماذا تفعل ومتى تفكر فقط
لا يمكن أن يحدث شيء أسوأ من ذلك ،
فأنت ترى فجأة صاروخًا في طريقك
وتحاول توجيه سيارة الإسعاف بعيدًا
عنها وهذا هو الوضع الإقليمي
الذي نحن
فيه حقًا وهذا سبب آخر
لعدم استمرار العمل كالمعتاد